foreign
well you know I don't know you don't
know I don't know I just noticed that it
happened
[Laughter]
look how blue we look yeah your hair
looks blue blue uh I have a blue wig on
in case you didn't there's a blue blue
yeah if it's even even our [__] soft
bounces
it usually is because I have it on the
cooler setting yeah because for some
reason I kind of like the cooler setting
more than the warm setting even though
they always say oh people's flesh looks
better and warm setting I I disagree I
think it makes me look orange because
you're trying to get that damn
cadaverous power well yeah that might be
it too like I don't really like I don't
want to look like I'm [__] tan or
anything [__] that or like you're a
living person yeah nobody who the [__]
wants that not me that's for sure
all right so we're gonna do uh the
professional also know whether Leon the
Professional the professional or
sometimes it's just called Leon or
sometimes it's just called the
professional or something it's called
Leon colon the professional which is
what Wikipedia listed as I saw this when
it came out the theatrical cut I liked
it uh we watched the uh Extended Cut
which I heard somebody else call it like
the French cut I think I've sort of
called like the long version the
international cut because that's the
version that was shown like in Europe
and stuff like that for the American
Market
um please correct me if I'm wrong but
I've think I read that for the American
Market I think 20 minutes was cut out of
it
yeah well I do remember remember I don't
really remember the original cut okay I
don't either it's been a long time yeah
it's been a long time
but I did remember thinking that it was
a good movie but like there there was
that it was vague and and left some to
be desired well explain it this movie
here
seems more like a a complete movie and
that was satisfying
a satisfying movie so
I don't remember what was added but it
must have made a difference
well I think as far as I'm aware I
believe there was believe but I think it
was like between 20 or 25 minutes it was
cut out of the American version
almost all of that was
um the extended scenes of like the
developing relationship between Leon and
Matilda okay yeah um so a lot of the
more quote-unquote like overtly I guess
sexualized kind of stuff that was in
there like all of that was taken out and
I think later on in the third act I
think they took out some stuff that made
it clear that she was helping him on his
jobs like she was essentially like an
accomplice yeah
um yeah she was actually there so
assistant assassin right so I think they
took most of that out so I think that
was kind of like the twin but like I
said xanadas sent us uh the Blu-ray for
this
so thank you very much for that xanada
and it had both the theatrical cut and
the long version I was like well
obviously we gotta watch the
international I don't want to watch a
movie with like a bunch of [__] trimmed
out I mean come on now I do remember
thinking that when I first saw it that
it was like you know basically it was
kind of like a almost like a pedo movie
all right
well we'll get into that yeah that was
the impression that I remembered having
but this version where there's more left
in it actually
disambiguates that
when you're leaving that [__] ambiguous
I'm thinking pedo [__] okay but when it
was shown in its entirety no no she was
in love with it but he wasn't doing
anything with her right it makes it
clear that he he's like it's her and
it's because of her upbringing and what
went down with her and her family
getting wiped out and [__] like that he
didn't think this was a good idea
and it makes it clear in the movie that
that he wasn't sleeping with a girl
he thought she was kind of crazy
well he understood that that was not
appropriate I think yeah I mean from and
it's kind of ironic because I feel like
knowing you know roughly what scenes
were removed like for the US version
like you said I think taking this [__]
out made it seem even worse than it
actually was because it removed a lot of
context yeah now I will note okay so
here's the thing because this is gonna
have to be addressed at some point so
the director of this Luke best song uh
you know who obviously did Fifth Element
uh La Femme Nikita stuff like that this
was actually
um a little bit of a same I don't know
if it was the same universe but it was
like uh inspired by La Femme Nikita
because John Reno played a character
named Victor the cleaner in that and so
this is like an expanded version of that
character from that movie although
there's another movie that this is I
think a direct rip off of but go ahead
but uh Luke basan
very famously okay do you remember the
scene in this movie where
um it's kind of like it's Leon's one of
the first assassinations that he shows
where he kills all those guys and then
he goes to that one main guy and he ends
up not killing that guy like he has like
the knife against his throat and at one
point like there's that guy's girlfriend
or a hooker or whatever and she like
she's like but I'm out of here she
leaves yeah okay so that woman she was a
hooker May when yeah
um that at the time was Luke besson's
wife okay now Luke Besson met her when
she was 12 years old and he was 29. okay
and started dating her when she was 15.
okay they got married and she had a baby
at 16. oh God so this movie is a little
bit
autobiographical no stop it I guess no
like Chief said that may win said that
okay she said this was actually kind of
based on our relationship from back then
because it was but the thing about it
was that I think I don't know if this is
true or not but in the original
screenplay and you know this is just
what I read so I don't know this is
somebody might have just made this up
but I heard that in the original
screenplay
um that Leon and Matilda did have sex
Jean Reno the actor that plays Leon he
was like he's like bro I'm not doing
that right okay so he actually made the
decision to he he specifically said I
wanted to play Leon as kind of
slow or kind of you know emotionally you
know simple or something like that he's
like just to make it clear that I wasn't
into her like that you know what I mean
because he wanted to and really if you
watch the movie because I know some
people are grossed out by it and that's
totally valid like I get it it is creepy
but it's I think it walks the line well
because I got the impression that he saw
her like as a daughter yeah you know
what I mean or like a protege like
someone to protect he was trying to take
care of her he didn't he didn't whereas
roots or anybody right about you know
and he came from a bad relationship and
she needed him
yeah her family just got assassinated
and he could have left her out there in
the hallway to get killed with the rest
of them but he took her in and the other
assassins didn't see it happen they
thought she lived there so he saved her
yeah but then he wanted her to leave but
she couldn't leave she was 12. where's
she gonna go she didn't have any family
or anything
so he couldn't just kick her out
until she became dependent on him she
looked up to him like I think
like a dad
but she didn't like her dad so she
couldn't distance that she was
fantasizing that it was her boyfriend
yeah and so she she had a big crush on
him type of deal
but nothing happens in the movie
yeah uh and in a way in the movie She's
a little bit more she's a little smarter
than he is I think she's kind of yeah he
said that he wanted to play it like that
so she looked like she had more power
yeah in the relationship you know what I
mean yeah it's a it's a beauty and the
beast kind of tale yeah and you're not
the first person to compare this to that
but yeah so I do think that because see
the thing about it is that yeah she
absolutely does and in the Extended Cut
if you haven't seen it I'm pretty sure
they took these scenes out of the
theatrical version but there is one
scene where they're at dinner and she's
like drinking champagne and she straight
up propositions him yeah for sex like
she wants him to take her virginity and
he's just like um no I'm not going there
um but the thing about it is that you're
not I don't think now even though Luke
Besson you know there's some
questionable [__] going on there because
he also had like a bunch of women like
accuse him of sexual assault like later
on so great but um you know not great
but uh so the thing about it is
regardless of like if the director is a
creep or not which I mean I guess he
kind of is if he's dating somebody
that's 12 years old like when he was 29
that's pretty creepy yeah but regardless
of that like just as the movie comes
across she comes across as a damaged
person I mean she obviously had this
horrible family life she couldn't stand
her family they all got wiped out
including her [__] four-year-old
brother which was the only family member
that she even gave a [__] about so she
just gone through this horrible horrible
trauma she's completely orphaned she
doesn't have anywhere to go and she
never really learned how to have any
healthy relationships yeah so the first
adult that comes in and is nice to her
and takes care of her she's going to
misplace her feelings on him and she
absolutely did like say she was in love
with him and she wanted to have sex with
him and stuff like that but he wasn't
having it yeah and they you know they
show that
it wasn't just her you know her mom was
real rough on her but her sister was
beating her up and her dad was basically
neglecting her he didn't like her either
um and then you find out that most of
those people in that family weren't
directly related to her
uh it was like half sisters and step
sisters and stepmoms the only one that
was related only to the related to her
were was her dad and her little brother
yeah and she's really avenging in the
death of her little brother she didn't
really care she says the other one's got
what they deserve basically yeah she
said the other ones were [__] and
they were kind of a gangster family yeah
the dad specifically yeah and um but
Leon keeps finding her out in the
hallways sneaking cigarettes and she's
all beat up you know because their
family members are beating her up
and uh
he tries to she tries to I think she
tries to run from her family and
make friends with him basically yeah but
he's not really want to make friends
with this girl
because he's got killing to do man he's
a [__] assassin he's busy he's got a
plant to take yeah and he's real kind of
emotionally cold
he doesn't have any friends really
and no real life he just
takes these contracts kills people and
then really doesn't get the money for it
the guy that is holding his money is has
spent his money he doesn't have it yeah
I'm kind of suspecting I yeah uh Danny
Aiello is like great in this as old Tony
who's like his the mafioso or whatever
that he works for and that dude is kind
of a piece of [__] I mean he's
essentially just taking advantage of
Leon because Leon isn't The Brightest
Bulb but he's also like [__] hot at what
he does like he's a really good assassin
so he's basically like yeah we're gonna
give you this money like five thousand
dollars per head and I was kind of when
they said five thousand dollars per
assassination I was like wow what a
bargain uh you would have thought it
would be more than that but anyway so
he's supposedly getting all that money
and old Tony is like well you know
you're not that good with money so I'm
gonna keep it all for you I'm like
[__] your keyboard yeah well he was
illiterate he couldn't read right and I
guess he didn't know numbers so he's
taking advantage he's basically and that
was the shitty thing too is like at the
end when Matilda goes to him for a job
and he basically says the same thing
he's like oh well all that money that
Leon said that I have that I'm holding
for him I'll hold it for you too you
know here's a hundred dollars like get
the [__] out of here like go be a
prostitute on this like what's the
little girl gonna do you know what I
mean she's [__] 12. well they should
be [__] pieces of [__] it's my future
yeah he's really a piece of [__] even
though he comes across he's a great
character I've you know I really like
that actor he's in a ton of movies but
um he just comes across as he comes
across as very like avuncular and he's
like you know always I'm so nice and all
this other kind of stuff but he's
absolutely a piece of [__] what
impresses me about the movies first of
all there's a lot of cool guns in it
especially 90s guns
um the acting's very good on all
accounts so every character the acting
is really good the writing is good the
long version explains the relationship
in more detail and it's it's a lot more
credible
what's going on it explains how the why
why the why Matilda's into this guy
Jenny basically explained it you know
she's been through a lot of [__] man
this is the only person that's helped
her
yeah so she's gonna you know she's gonna
displace her feelings of like oh this is
like the White Knight this is like the
person not Saved Me Like Somebody
whipped in and she's trying yeah she's
trying to impress him but she can be an
assassin too right but it's all fantasy
it all comes crashing down on her in the
end anyway she did help out but she
didn't do much she just [__] talked
to people through the doors and stuff
she's more like a decoy
um I don't remember her she didn't kill
anybody
did she no she didn't I don't think she
did she just acted as a decoy basically
um
Natalie [__] knocks it out of the
park this [__] girl could act even
this was her first movie man she's
amazing in this Crying On Demand crying
out of commands and [__] pull off an
Oscar when in performance I remember
seeing it when it came out and like me
and all my friends was what 1990
something 1994 1994 we were in the Army
at the time on my arm but it's like man
have you seen that [__] move you set
girl we were all impressed with her you
know we're like how old is that girl you
know we thought that she might have been
a
mid-teens or something like playing
younger but no she's not she's playing
12. she is 12. yeah same age yeah we
were all we were all like man she's cute
man she she's got to be 15 16 doing the
you know doing uh with the acting skills
no she's 12. yeah she's great though
[__] I mean you can see why she
became a huge [__] yeah
because she wasn't famous you know to us
when this came out we didn't yeah like I
said this was the first movie that she
was yeah we even know that girl's name
turned out is Natalie [__]
Portman she's [__] been in everything
made millions of dollars and she's great
in everything she never I've never seen
her dial anything again she's good and
everything yeah she's a fantastic guy um
and can do a wide variety of stuff
um I would think this [__] playing
Princess Amidala was actually one of her
weaker roles and that's she's well known
and she's still good at it she's still
good at it though but um she's honestly
one of the better one of the best things
yeah
uh although the dude who plays
obi-walking always good in it too so
it's funny McGregor yeah it's so special
McGregor knocks it out of the park and
of course the emperor yeah you know but
um what's the guy who did mace wind do
[__] uh [__]
Samuel L Jackson yeah Sam Jackson he's
the [__] he's good in whatever he's in
he could have found it in and it's still
good
like he phoned in Kong if you ask me and
that's still [__] great but conks
call Island yeah he found that in and
that's still great yes yeah he was just
he played himself yeah yeah it was it
was good I don't know I always feel like
I'm repressed because I'm not a big fan
of kid actors like kids in movies so she
was great in this but well that's what I
was gonna say was that so when you see a
performance from a [__] kid I mean
like I said she's 12.
that mature that [__] I was just like
man she was like [__] amazing yeah
and her parents really did not want her
to do this movie by the way I mean you
can kind of see why I don't think her
career would have really gone anywhere
without her doing this movie and yeah
she acknowledges that this movie made
she's like this is basically yeah she
said this movie handed me my career on a
silver platter like I said she's she
finds it like problematic nowadays
because of um she's like I didn't know
about Luke Besson at the time like about
the [__] with the 12 year old girlfriend
and all that kind of crap uh she's like
because I was just a kid I didn't know
anything she's like so you know I have a
more complicated relationship with it
nowadays but she's like um you know
absolutely that movie gave her her
career that was her breakout role yeah
in order to keep [__] society saying
you got to have [__] rules about
[__] uh children all right but weird
[__] has happened I've known people in
my extended goth [__] Universe
especially down in New Orleans
to have saved underage people from
[__] bad life in the streets by
letting them stay with him for a few
years and then they [__] ended up
being of legal age
but
you know what I mean [__] I don't
think any sex is happening with that
either it was just
We're not gonna let this person be
homeless you know yeah there are
runaways that's kind of different yeah
it's like that's the thing you never
really you don't want to like tip so far
in the other direction that you think
everybody is like a predator because
they're not like some people are
actually just being helpful the girl I'm
talking about
Jenny probably knows who it is I don't
know if I've told her the story
it was my one of my buddies girlfriends
at the time
years before I met them
she ran away from home running from an
abusive father
she didn't have a home to go back to
he was a few years older than her but
she was about 14. and he took her in
yeah because what are you gonna do you
can't send her back to her dad right and
uh
so and what are you gonna do leave her
on the streets
of New Orleans she's going to end up
being a hooker right
so and she's a goth girl you're not
gonna just let her just walk around
yeah you know so he took her in
you know three years later she was
younger or she was eight you know legal
and no one was looking for
right you know what I mean
and what are you gonna do hand her over
to the state
in the in New Orleans area that'd be
even worse you might as well hand them
over a prison
so
I don't understand certain circumstances
you know I mean that's kind of the
circumstances Leon was in
yeah and he was a criminal like I said
he didn't hand her over to anybody right
and well she I mean the the and the bad
guys we're looking for the bad guy DEA
guys were looking for they knew what she
looked like too because they saw the
photos and they knew she was missing he
had no choice but to take a Rin just for
humanitarian purposes yeah
because the thing about it I kind of
feel like too in the original iteration
or the original script I think that he
was a lot more cold-blooded
um in the sense that uh he even when he
was training her I think he's just like
let her shoot random people yeah whereas
in the movie you kind of think that he's
gonna do that because remember like the
one scene where he's showing her you'd
use the scope and everything and they go
up on the roof and you think oh my God
because she's like well who should I
shoot and he's like oh whoever you know
what I mean you're like oh my God are
they just gonna like shoot a random
person like to train her but it's just
like a paint gun you know what I mean
um but I think in the actual in the
original script I think that she did
actually just like shoot random people
so she did actually kill people and
think but so they toned it down for the
movie some because probably somebody
said Loop us on for Christ's sake what
are you even doing but you know because
well that's the thing even though Leona
is a criminal obviously he's a Hitman
but he's still like sympathetic this
movie is a lot more
um like the relationship between them
yeah you could say that it has like
creepy overtones but it's actually kind
of sweet you know what I mean I always
to me like like I said he seems more
like her dad
you know what I mean he's like very
protective of her like a dad or like a
big brother type of character it comes
across more like that to me because like
I said he's very clearly not down with
her
in the end in the end he did say that he
loved her yeah but it wasn't a a sexual
thing
he loved her like she was a daughter he
was trying to protect her yeah he
basically died for basically and then
made sure that she got supposedly got
some money but I don't think she got the
bikes
yeah because I don't think Tony didn't
have any so he didn't have the money
although she had she had money right but
she stole the money from her dad like
out of the apartment right because the
DEA guys didn't find it but didn't she
use that well she was trying to use some
of it to like hire a higher hit to hire
Leon to kill the people because that was
her whole thing she just wanted to kill
them because they had killed her little
brother uh some tuition Money prepaid so
she went back to that school and I think
she uh I think they let her stay there
like as a charity case and that was yeah
well they said they established at the
beginning that her dad had paid the
year's tuition in advance and she had
just like run away like at some point
just you know a few weeks earlier or
something like that so I'm assuming that
she could at least stay there for the
rest of the school year yeah
um you know so she actually did have a
supporting school so she actually did
have a place to go that was actually
more age-appropriate instead of like
running around being a Hitman
um there was actually they were thinking
about doing
um a sequel to this when she was like a
couple of years older and she was
actually have gonna have become a
cleaner because that was like her her
career aspiration but they didn't end up
doing it like it just kind of went
through too many iterations and blah
blah and then I think he ended up making
another movie that I think was called
Colombiana which was kind of like the
same kind of story like about a female
cleaner but it was originally supposed
to be about her like when she was older
so can we talk a little bit about Gary
[__] old men yeah in this because
this is back when [__] old Gary was
doing crazy roles and [__] he did a good
job of this Gary Oldman in this is he is
[__] off the charts insane but it's
so [__] great he's so great it really
works crushing pills in his teeth and
[__] having spasms and [__] but never
did explain what drug that was
yeah they never did say you were just
supposed to wonder or something bad
something that makes it sound like a
turtle make your neck stretch out
stretch out and look up the ceiling
[Laughter]
kind of like that didn't blue velvet and
hailing that laughing gas it's like
Frank boots
oh [__] anything that moves yeah yeah
but that's the thing so the very famous
oh my God I don't think we've ever
reviewed blue velvet have we yeah that's
a weird movie did we I mean it's not my
favorite David Lynch movie that would be
Mulholland Drive but it's up there it's
it's [__] awesome movie but the thing
like Gary Oldman you know the very very
famous see it's like a meme now where
you know the guy's like you know hey go
get everyone he's like what do you mean
everyone he's like everyone you know
what I mean like he [__] goes
hardcore with it The Story Goes and Gary
Oldman this is right from Gary oldman's
mouth
he says I did that take as a joke I was
just trying to make the director laugh
he's like because I had done that scene
over like 50 times or something like
that and I just kind of said it
different each time he's like mostly I
just said it normal like yeah get
everyone you know what I mean
um but then he's like I thought I would
be funny so I go over the sound guy like
surreptitiously and I said hey um I'm
gonna yell really loud so like take your
headphones off because I don't want to
like blast your ears out and then so
like when they did that next taking he's
like everyone and then like Luke bassan
was like oh my God I love that I'm
putting that in the movie and he's like
I didn't mean for that to be in the
movie he's just like I just thought it
was funny but yeah so it ended up in the
movie and that probably ended up being
the same he said that he's still to this
day has people coming up to him doing
that because it's in like I said it's
like a [__] meme nowadays like the
[__] is the fact that he does that but
he's just like a great [__] villain
also can we talk about I mean if you
haven't seen this movie sorry but we're
gonna do like spoiler alerts because
come on it's 1994. get get with the
program
um I had forgotten I saw this movie back
in the 90s but I don't think I'd seen it
again since then so I had forgotten uh
what happened at the end
and wow that the end is a bummer it's a
bummer because you kind of do
even though Leon is a Hitman obviously
that's not good
um you do kind of want to see if like
and he kills a lot of people a lot of
people it's like a large body count so
you do kind of want to see him get away
though and like meet up with because
that whole scene where he's like
blasting the wall out and he's like you
know helping her escape and I'll meet
you at Tony's in an hour and you're just
sitting there going I just know this is
not gonna he's not gonna meet her in an
hour and he probably knows that too I
mean you know what I mean so it's just
like really really sad and then like it
seems like he almost gets away
but then because he's good you know he
like dresses up like the all the um the
SWAT guys or whatever and like he's
pretends he's injured and he like sneaks
out but [__] Gary Oldman he sees him
but Gary Oldman shoots him in the
[__] back like a [__] yeah
maybe you want to die yeah that's true
he didn't want to die he's like yeah
this is probably the safest way to
approach the situation because this
[__] has killed like every other
person like it killed like his whole
entire like basically Batman
[__] be up in the scene thing
and [__] he could get you with wires
and pull you up and [__] drop down on
the ceiling head custom [__]
custom lce which is like a
load carrying equipment to carry
grenades and
weapons and magazines suppressed pistols
and
he's he's equipped
I don't know what kind of grenades those
were they were cylindrical
I didn't see anything like it sometimes
yeah I never saw one it's like some kind
of a foreign grenade something European
a lot of the gun they had real cool guns
in this
a lot of stuff confused me though I
wasn't really sure because like I guess
it's supposed to be New York right it is
New York yeah okay because and actually
a lot of it was filmed like that
exteriors are filming when the New York
SWAT team showed up they showed up with
a bunch of European stuff Swiss rifles
Sig their little Sig rifles I thought it
was called 225 or what I don't know what
that thing was called it was like a
piston 556 assault rifle kind of like a
real sophisticated AK that Sig used to
make they had those they had fouls
or actually look like a 556 foul type
rifle maybe like a Brazilian in Bell or
something
oh they had
some kind of a German belt fed machine
gun look like 762.
it wasn't an mg42 it was something more
modern than that it had that so they
were so they're carrying European
weapons mp5s and [__]
and uh New York SWAT teams didn't have
that then in the 90s they were carrying
German stuff
so I was it was just that's what that's
whatever Armory they hired had they had
good yeah I mean it's a French film
French yeah okay I mean that's why it's
a friendship right it probably wasn't
filmed in in in New York no they did uh
the exteriors were filmed in New York
and I believe that
um the interior of the apartment
building where um where Leon lived I
think that was the Chelsea Hotel very
famous for some reason you know where
Nancy sponge and got killed for some
reason uh they sourced a bunch of a
bunch of European stuff for the cops but
I think a lot of the Interiors were shot
in Paris though because like I said this
is a French film it's a French director
French crew everything like that New
York SWAT teams would have all been
carrying [__] M16s American stuff
maybe in mp5s they would have had that
but yeah does SF use those but some of
the other [__] was like wow why the hell
I got that but they do have cool guns in
there a lot of
90s era mini Uzis this is the folding
stock Newsies
um a lot of cool pistols CC 75 type
stuff
um it was all kind of things that you
would actually see back then you know so
whoever did most of the guns I you know
it was uh good choices on stuff I just
would have given the
New York Police Department M16 some
America and stuff that's what they would
really have yeah but like I said maybe
it was just kind of that's not what they
had on his hand I guess and I mean this
wasn't like a hugely budgeted but I
think it only cost like 15 16 million to
make which was fairly small
um budget I mean it made like you know
most of its all of its uh money back and
then some because it was pretty
successful actually in Europe and
elsewhere even though like I said in the
US it was cut down substantially but it
even then like it got good uh critical
reviews but yeah so I I don't know I
kind of feel like
um somebody was saying down here uh
Jones Perkins said shoot him in the back
is reminiscent of John Dillinger and
Bonnie and Clyde the authorities were so
terrified of them that they would kill
them in Cold Blood yeah and I kind of
feel like that man I'm gonna say like
the French that when they make movies
they don't [__] around you know what I
mean especially I mean this movie The
Gangsters or they were they were
actually DEA agents they were all like
crooked yeah they were [__] brutal
man they just like came in that house
and they just like [__] they blew
that woman away in the bathtub they shot
that teenage girl in the back yeah they
shot that four-year-old kid that was
like hiding under the bed it's like they
did not give a single [__] yeah about
Bonnie and Clyde though they weren't
given a choice that was Frank Hamer
and uh he was like
the new pattern for law enforcement
which is just get [__] done those dudes
were a [__] Menace and
Clyde Barrow and [__] body were good
they were really good they actually
trained with their weapons and they had
a bunch of custom
uh weapons like cut down bars uh Bonnie
could fire on the move and hit another
man who was also running at about 150
meters they were good real good they
weren't like slack slack
so they weren't like Slackers when it
came to [__] firearms and they could
drive
they had already killed so many law
enforcement agents you couldn't take any
chances with them so they just set up a
very standard Ambush when the car came
down the road and it got in the middle
they would yell at Open Fire and
everybody would just unload at the
[__] their car
that's how they got them yeah a lot of
it was uh bars and
um Remington 35s
um
but it was I think it was most and I
don't even think they might have been
some Thompsons but
I don't know maybe not I think it was
mostly bars 30 out six because it'd go
through those cars
Thompson sub machine gun wasn't very
effective
in that era against Vehicles because 45
ACP isn't isn't a very good
penetrator when it comes to thick sheet
metal that those cars were made of in
those days a lot of people didn't like
them they were good indoors though and
good against soft targets but if you're
in a vehicle Thompson isn't really what
you wanted and I don't think they would
have carried that there was people that
were complaining about it there was an
alternate to the
Thompson submachine got an alternate
caliber called 38 Super
it was kind of like an American version
of nine millimeter it was a heavier
bullet but and going a little bit slower
but it was it was also good it was a lot
better
at armor piercing the British bought a
bunch of those because it was better and
had a better rage better than 45 so I
don't know
but then we didn't make that many of
those that was the deal about 30th super
but hey I'm going down a [__] gun
rabbit hole trembling color said movie
Firearms database is a cool site to go
yeah
I check and I go what the [__] was that
I'll pause okay yeah okay because
sometimes he looks up like the cars in
films too like if there's like a cool
guy what car was that uh sometimes you
just get a glimpse of some firearm and
the angle and the lighting is kind of
crazy or not quite sure what that was
was that a cz-75 or was that a Browning
high power there's some [__] that looks
very similar on screen
you know or I'll see some guys firing
off 1911s and I'm like that's not right
that's that that looks too skinny and
then you go back and check out no it's a
star model b and nine millimeter it's
not a 1911 and do you see a lot of that
in gangster movies they're carrying 1911
45s but then when the shootout breaks
out you look and the dimension's a
little bit off because they switched
them to nine millimeters yeah they'll
switch it to like star model B's which
looks like a 45 but it's nine and
and they want that for movies because
nine millimeter blanks are a lot more
reliable than 45 blanks because the
pressure isn't there nine millimeter
gives a higher pressure so it Cycles
more reliably they don't Jam as much and
they make a bigger pop or a little bit
bigger Fireball so it looks better on
screen
uh that's one of the reasons why people
the like we talked about this before on
other other shows
Mac 10s had a bad
um reliability rep had a reputation for
bad reliability
but not in real life
they had a bad reputation for
reliability in the movies because
most of the Mac 10s they first were
dealing with were 45 and 45 blanks don't
work very well and uh Mac in a Mac 10
45. so because they jammed a lot the
people making the movies thought Mac 10s
jammed a lot they didn't they only
jammed with 45 blanks
if you switched it to nine millimeter
they worked well because there's more
pressure
it was like the one snake pliskin is
using and
and uh Escape From New York is a nine
millimeter that's why it's running so
good
hahaha
I've had them before I [__] love the
back tens and they they've got internals
for the new Max that make them think so
[__] sweet because there's a lot of
Mac chassis out there that are
transferable
it means that you can buy and transfer
them in the United States
easily and uh there's all these upgrade
kits for those things now you can make
those things Swedish [__] tungsten
[__] bolt carrier groups slow the
firing rate down [__] better triggers
different uppers there's all kinds of
stuff
Jones Perkins says this is one of my
favorite movies uh she asked him is life
always this hard and he tells her yes
life is always this hard I actually
really did love that scene that was like
one right before they met like they were
out in the hall and she says something
like is life always this harder is it
just because I'm a kid and he just
basically says always like this yeah he
says but he's he John Reno is like so I
think this might be I haven't seen a ton
of stuff that he's in but I have seen
like a you know a handful of movies that
he's in and I think this is probably his
most iconic role this is for sure what
made him like famous in the U.S because
he doesn't talk all that much
but you really get a good sense of his
character regardless just like from his
facial expressions and like the way he
like he's very stoic and he's you know
you know a cold-blooded killer and stuff
like that but you get a sense of the
person that's going on behind there just
from his body language and stuff like
that so it's like a really really good
uh performance I think yeah Frankie Capo
also says my favorite movie it's for
sure like one of the best crime movies
and one of the best movies of the 90s
and I'm actually I liked it a lot when I
saw it the first time in the 90s I don't
remember if I saw this in the theater or
if I just saw it I might have rented it
like when it came out like a year or two
later
so I'm pretty sure I didn't see this in
the theater but I remember liking it
quite a bit then but that was probably
the theatrical cut because I don't think
you could get the international cut over
here until you know recently until it
came out on DVD or Blu-ray or whatever
um so I probably would have seen the
theatrical cut so maybe I didn't like it
as much but seeing it now like with all
the stuff back in like I said it really
gives a lot more context yeah I can see
why some of the scenes got taken out but
like we were saying earlier I think them
taking them out like almost made it seem
worse because it made their relationship
seem more ambiguous and you could kind
of read [__] into it whereas like if you
see all the scenes in there intact yeah
some of them are uncomfortable and stuff
like that but they're supposed to be
yeah like I said she's not a healthy
person like she doesn't have like this
the psychology like the healthy
psychology of a normal 12 year old girl
she's messed up I mean she's traumatized
she's been abused her entire life and
she doesn't really
know how to process her emotions so
she's you know like I said the first
person that comes in is like nice to her
she's imprinting on that person this is
and like you know thinking she's in love
with them and she's you know just on the
cusp of Womanhood I guess and she
doesn't really know how to deal with
that either so she's
you know trying to sexualize herself
really and so he's just kind of like
yeah no we're not like [__] going
there in colors uh trembling colors that
I was looking up that ultra rare finish
submachine gun Stallone using Cobra on
there called the uh what's that called
the jadomatic Thematic I think yeah SMG
apparently it was a terrible terrible
gun you know what's funny we were just
watching uh Oliver Harper just put up a
video about Cobra just a couple days
yeah probably reminded him of it um I
hadn't thought of that gun in a long
time but I remember when it came out new
they were doing reviews on it they did
shooting reviews in the rags back then
we had magazines that talked about the
[__] I remember which one it was but I
had subscriptions it was probably
something like a SWAT or or automatic
automatic weapons was another one that I
[__] uh had a subscription to
and uh they reviewed it and said it was
great so it probably depended on who it
was you were talking to
maybe it wasn't any good with blanks
because that was blowback operated it
wasn't gas operated it uh it just it was
just a spring holding a heavy bolt
forward
and uh that spring delayed
the amount of time before the bolt
opened up allowing the cycle to continue
there wasn't any lock to it but it was
at a weird angle
the back of the weapon was kind of
kicked up so the boat kind of didn't
come straight back it kind of went up at
an angle like that and then came down
which was slowed the cyclic rate down
because I
open boat
blowback operated submachine guns when
they're that small [__] have a real
high firing rate then back then there
were ways to mechanically slow it down
but they didn't get into that they're
trying to keep the cost down
probably wasn't a design that worked
real well with blanks
but I read reviews back then of it fire
they were fired live Admiral with it and
they loved it it had a weird feature
you could pull the bolt to the rear and
it would lock to the rear you could do
it manually it had a lever I think it
was on the top
but in other ways that the foregrip
could pull back and it could push the
bolt to the rear so you could
carry it around in a safe condition and
then just pull back on the forward grip
and put it into firing condition because
it's it's dangerous if you're a soldier
walking around with a damn bolt to the
rear over a live magazine
you could drop it and the bulk is slip
skip over the [__] sear and fire off
around
that was one of the big troubles with
blowback
and if you're in the field carrying a
[__] ready to fire the bolts open man
[__] dirt and [__] could fall down
inside that open breach it's firing from
an open breach it's not a real good way
of doing it it's a cheap way of doing it
but in the field it
there's risks that think of fall in
there and [__] come up it works but
um I heard it was good
I heard it was real good
but it was a gun of its era they don't
make things like that anymore it's
[__] sheet metal they make all that
[__] out of polymer now
murder Hornet says what I want to know
is what pills was Gary Oldman was
getting so high yeah yeah we were
wondering about that too it's like
because there were these big huge
you don't need that [__]
I was watching another podcast of like a
review where they had like a big long
discussion about this movie and the
woman was saying she's like she's like
yeah what the [__] were those pills it's
like she's like I always felt like they
were the pills that he took to like to
keep himself from starting to get to a
werewolf I like the way he was acting
and I'm like yeah they were kind of like
that I kind of like that they don't tell
you what they are though yeah because
you know there's in those big huge
[__] like they're green capsules
right and he just has I mean he's in the
DEA so I'm assuming he can get the good
[__] but I mean it made him like it's
like well he wasn't like necessarily he
was psychotic but he was like kind of
like all over the place like up and down
because sometimes he was very but I
think that's what made him scary because
he was a little like erratic like
sometimes he would be but like that long
speech he gave about Beethoven and all
that kind of stuff like he seemed very
calm and all that but then like he was
just he would just like wig out suddenly
yeah that scene where he sniffs that guy
too yeah I heard he's trying to smell
the fear I heard you're trying to spell
a lot that the actor playing the guy
that got sniffed who was you know
Natalie Natalie Portman's character's ad
um or wait was it yeah yeah no
because he was the one that was hiding
the drugs right and he's like no I'm
totally not cutting your drugs right
right so he's apparently the actor
playing him did not know that Gary
Oldman was gonna get close and start
sniffing him that's good so he's like so
the the reaction that you see on his
face is an absolute genuine reaction
like what the [__] is this [__]
doing right now that's good that's good
yeah yeah good actors will do that and
then good actor reacts to it and he
knows what's going on right oh this is
great
Gary Oldman is smelling me right now
this dude knows this role because now
you got something to play off of
uh he says something about more about
the the jathy Matic
uh trembling color said um yeah that
review made me re-watch the movie yeah
see that's what yeah we just watched it
yeah like two days ago it was a good
review man because he was like oh Oliver
Harper put a new one up because I love
Oliver Harper but yeah he put one up of
code I want to review Cobra now now what
do you say
um he said maybe rewatch that movie then
look up the gun watch The Forgotten
Weapons review okay you know who that is
and uh yeah yeah that for that's a good
uh Channel yeah you like she likes his
voice what's his name again yeah he has
like a he has a real relaxing voice that
guy I don't know what it is he's an arms
curator yeah and he comes on and talks
about he just sounds so friendly I don't
know yeah he is he's he just sounds like
a very friendly dude he's a gunner yeah
and he knows everything about everything
like because sometimes like Tom like
will listen to it sometimes and I'll
like hear it in the background yeah
he said it had a progressive the
complaint was they had a progressive
trigger with a progressive trigger yeah
I forgot about that feature if I
remember correctly if you pulled the the
trigger back just a slightly like a
little bit you'd get a single shot like
semi-auto and then you could reset that
over again I think and then if you kept
continued pulling it would it engage a
full auto series and Go full auto on you
that would be that if if that's what it
what you're talking about yeah that'd be
a bad solution you don't need that
that [__] just get in the way of [__]
you know it just it's something like a a
sub gun like that open bolt sub guns got
to be rock and roll straight full auto
you know what it is you and just let it
run like that you don't need that
semi-auto with feminacy let that [__] go
full
it's meant for a [__] close range
[__] gun fight inside a room you
don't need semi-auto
trembling colors also said I don't need
this Mickey Mouse [__] it's a great
phrase from him to use that overall is
just a great [__] scene where you
know he's the DEA guy right and the two
other guys who I'm assuming are
superiors or something and they're
taking him in the apartment where the
massacre of Natalie Portman's family
took place and they're basically asking
him to kind of like explain himself and
all he does he just very arrogantly he's
like well the dude was standing over
there and he pulled the gun out so I
[__] shot him and you know what I
mean and it's like so the guys are like
yeah but how about like all like the
women in the bathtub and all this stuff
yeah I don't need this Mickey Mouse
[__] he just like walks out and
they're just like okay they just like
allowed it so it's just like I'm
assuming that because he had all of
those other guys
like on his team and what was the deal
with the white Rasta dude
it's just there were lots of guys like
that back in the 90s that was like it
was just like a random dude it was just
like going through their record
collection it was kind of like back in
the 90s
like I kind of remember that in the 90s
had dreads yeah I remember that all
right I remember that was the thing the
whole thing where white dudes are gonna
be in a drum circle they're gonna
[__] take psychedelic drugs beat on
drums have dreadlocks and try to [__]
hippie girls that's I don't know why you
want to [__] them they don't shave but
you know hairy armpits and [__] but
that's what they were into they don't
bathe either so no no thanks
dirty ass flip-flop wearing checks and
[__] no oh and that dudes that were into
that you know that reminded me stinky
ass
you talking about uh hippies and stuff
like that kind of reminded me of I had
forgotten also that the uh the song
playing during the credits is Sting
uh in this movie so it's funny because
we were watching the movie and then the
sting comes on which what the [__] is
the name of that song
um the shape of my heart or whatever the
[__] it's called and I remember that
song like from back in the 90s but um so
that song comes on
like we both like cracked up and we're
like oh my God you never know like when
you're gonna expect sting in his lingam
yeah
at the end of time to get up in your
Yanni
yeah it was just so funny because we
were just [__] talking about staying
like on Friday like talking about talk
about his tantric tantric like you know
his girlfriend like riding his dick for
four hours yeah and then Zach's saying
it's like his wife is over there reading
a magazine because she's like super
bored
when I was a kid Focus Sting's purpose
was to talk his way up into your
girlfriend's [__] that's that's what he
was here for yeah I'm here to talk my
way up into your girlfriend's [__] well
at least he's being awesome yeah yeah
that trembly color said the white roster
got reminded me of Gary Oldman from True
Romance that's right that's another one
we had like somebody brought that up
before earlier because they were talking
about Gary Oldman being a great villain
in that yeah and yeah man that was a
great movie too and I haven't seen that
in a really long time yeah we really
need to like revisit that one that was
all [__] Christian Slater's best
movie if he asked me
um yeah I mean he was in some good [__]
he was in Heather's he was in Pump Up
the Volume I really like Pump Up the
Volume yeah they were okay but true he
that didn't compare to True Romance I
thought but true that's great it's great
yeah
um yeah term like colors if it takes
longer than 20 minutes then you're both
doing it wrong
yeah I'm not really sure what they're
doing for four hours it's just I'm just
sitting there going don't you guys have
anything else you need to be doing it's
just I don't know I don't know but
that's like that's really funny so I
didn't I had forgotten that there was a
sting song at the end of this
[Laughter]
all right so you seem like you've
quieted down so I guess we're not
talking about guns anymore so you're
just okay we're talking about the moon
we finished the movie though didn't we I
guess so yeah I mean yeah like I said I
know that some people still are like
weirded out by the whole you know adult
man 12 year old girl kind of thing I
guess not that weird but I think in
context yeah it didn't strike me as that
weird yeah it's weird that she's
kind of you know flirting with him and
stuff like that but that's just because
she's messed up like I said he doesn't
take her up on it it was although like I
said I heard that in the original
scripts he did he's just like oh yeah
totally and they had sex so that's
creepy for sure yeah and I'm glad they
didn't put that in the movie but I'm
just saying the movie as it stands and
the way that you know um that John Reno
played it you know he's very clearly
very uncomfortable with the way she's
acting because he sees her like as a
daughter yeah more than you know it's
just it's just the way you know
it was just a movie and things like that
really happened I mean [__]
well I remember when I was in high
school
[__] Middle School girls would
[__] just throw themselves at you
like you were a [__] rock star but
when you're
10th 11th grade you can't be caught dead
with a [__] eighth girl from eighth
grade you crazy doesn't matter you know
what I mean but they were there about
that age and
little [__] girls flirt you know what
I mean and [__] have
boyfriend fantasies yeah and I mean
they're they do they're little kids too
they don't really know the implications
but it's time to get to ninth grade and
[__] all that shit's calmed down they're
hiding all that yeah yeah
they know how to [__] keep that [__]
out of wraps
they do you know oh you remember what
they were like yeah yeah well I was one
you was you were one yeah
so so I know what that's it's not out
really that out of character as as
portrayed in the movie yeah and I mean I
think it was pretty accurate because I
knew some kids that age like girls that
age that absolutely did act like that
you know what I mean like they would act
like very overtly sexual they didn't
really know what they were doing or they
didn't really know what the larger
consequences of it were I don't know the
full impact right
um they're emulating adult Behavior yeah
and looking forward to when oh I'm you
know I'm you know I'm gonna have a
boyfriend you know what I mean they want
to have a boyfriend now but they're too
young yeah
um they wouldn't know what to do with
one because I mean the thing about it is
that I think a scene in this that a lot
of people were squicked out by was when
she was playing that Guess Who game and
she comes out like kind of dressed like
Madonna like she's doing like and she's
singing like a virgin yeah you know what
I mean but like I said she was just
pretending and then she does Marilyn
Monroe and she's singing all breathy
like happy Birthday Mr President yeah
yeah but um but yeah I'm gonna be
attractive as possible right like I said
she doesn't really yeah you see I was
gonna say you said that this movie was
kind of inspired by uh what was it uh
you mentioned the movie
but it's kind of this movie I love fan
Nikita well a character in Lafayette
yeah I would say it actually reminds me
more of another movie I saw
was just like this except it was
um the gender was gender swapped it's
called Gloria
and it's about old gangster girl she's
probably in her 50s and she's kind of
like a retired girlfriend of some
[__] gangster like I'm like a
gangster mall or whatever they call it
yeah I don't know what it was it's like
that's your that's your gangster
girlfriend you know what I mean and then
when she gets too old to be your
girlfriend you just kind of put her at
the passage replace her with a praise
her with a younger one yeah but she was
a badass too her name was Gloria
and she was retired gangster
and the family next to her was low end
gangsters
and the dad from there [__] runs over
with their little boy just here you hold
him you hold him real quick hold him for
me she's like I don't know and she's
like I don't want him she's out just for
a minute and she goes okay she brings
the kid in and the dad goes back to the
thing and the mob shows up and kills
that whole family because it was the
same thing stole money yeah now she's
stuck with this little boy God damn it
and he's probably about six or seven
maybe
and it's a similar situation she's
protecting this little boy the Bob's
coming to kill him
he thinks he's the man in the situation
he's trying to she goes I'm the man you
listen to me he goes oh you're the man
you know just it's just funny [__] you
know what I mean and uh she didn't never
had any kids and she's kind of taking
him on as like a kind of like a
surrogate kid you know right uh but he
thinks that she's his girlfriend right
and it's called Gloria I remember being
a real good movie I haven't seen it in a
long long time I wonder what year that
came out I mean I kind of early remember
I don't think I saw it but I think I'm
really feeling about it yeah and she
kills kills a bunch of dudes defending
this kid she's trying to get out of New
York about I believe I remember
correctly and I heard I think her
boyfriend did eventually show up in the
thing
and helped her Escape
with the boy it's called Gloria I
haven't heard of it in a long time
I want to see we had to see that one
again it was kind of like this
yeah and she wasn't an assassin she was
just a gangster girlfriend right but she
had guns
she used him to get the [__] out of
there
she was just kind of a
kind of a tough smart New York broad
broad I'm gonna call her abroad I like
bronze yeah because she was like from
that generation right you know this is
happening like a good broad yeah this is
happening like late 70s early 80s and
she's already like in her 50s so she'd
been around for a long time maybe 60s
did she like chain smoke and have like
one of those boys
exactly exactly I love that
all the lipstick on and the [__]
white hair that's what I'm gonna be like
when I'm 90.
and the [__] get the [__] off
yeah [__] revolver and the [__] I
can't wait and the leopard skin [__]
jackets and [__] you know [__] yeah yeah
that's Gloria I'm I'm gonna do that yeah
I'm gonna do that oh so you think you're
the man no you're the man oh yeah you're
the man yeah yeah kick your [__] yeah
exactly she's one of those
[__] awesome uh Camp guy said is La
Femme Nikita the one with the American
remake with eager with uh Bridget Fonda
yeah well no uh Le Femme Nikita was the
original French one yeah and then they
did an American remake which uh yeah
Charlie color said it was called point
of no return point no return that's
right which I saw I don't remember much
about it I remember really liking
Lafayette I like both I think I've seen
them both yeah I've seen them both I
liked them both I think if I remember
correctly I'm thinking like other Luke
basan movies that I've said I mean
obviously The Fifth Element I think
um I don't I don't know I might like
this one slightly More Than The Fifth
Element but I'm not really sure because
they're kind of like different movies I
will note though that one early Luke
Besson movie that um I had been looking
forward to re-watching because I
remembered seeing it back in the 80s and
I was gonna review it for my channel was
Subway and it was on shutter atrio Max
something like that and I started
watching it and I was like I couldn't
even finish it I was like man this thing
is like [__] a snoozer man and I had
forgotten like because I remembered it
being really cool like has Isabella
Johnny in it and like the dude that was
in Highlander and all that kind of [__]
so I was just kind of like man I
remember really liking this movie
because it was all kind of like new wave
and everything because it was like early
80s but I was watching it again I'm like
man this is really boring so I didn't
even like finish it I was gonna review
it for my channel but I didn't maybe
I'll like maybe I was just in a bad mood
that day I'll give it another go around
but um yeah try my colors just said
Subway isn't good but I yeah I just I
couldn't get into it but like I said
maybe it was just because that was the
mood that I was in that day I'll have to
give it another [__] go because I
remember liking it back in the 80s when
I first saw it but I don't know uh yeah
traveling collar said Gloria is a great
movie okay and there's a shitty 90s
remake with Sharon Stone
was it called Gloria also
the one with Sharon Stone because I
don't remember a movie with her like
that was called that
so you know people might [__] pick on
this movie to me it was a copy of Gloria
which I haven't seen in a long time I
want to see it again I remember liking
it I saw it a million times on HBO
when I was a kid
see I don't which is weird because I
probably would yeah because I kind of um
I saw like like millions and millions
movies like on HBO and Cinemax and stuff
like that when I was a kid because they
would you know they had like tons and
tons of movies
during the summer and so I saw a bunch
of them but I for some reason I always I
never saw that one it was good yeah it
had realistic combat like [__] that
gangsters would really do like they just
tried to run her over one time if I
remember correctly they're doing stuff
in in public everything like I remember
when they came at her a couple times it
was they tried to make it look like an
accident like it was something deniable
yeah I mean it wasn't just gunning her
down but it's been a long time I might
have that confused with something else
he he seems to Remember the movie we've
seen it more recently I just remember
that it was real gritty and it was I
remember it being very realistic
and uh cool it had good acting and it
had a dark
New York Indie feel to it
and the way it was It was kind of
depressing looking everything was real
run down it was yeah like New York like
New York was back then and [__] it
doesn't much look like that yeah and all
these base basically kind of like
two-bit gangsters in [__] old suits
and hats and [__] just show it up saying
a few things and then leaving you know
I'd kind of be curious to see it and see
if it really is as similar
um see the professor it's about the same
press about the same premise just gender
swapped right
oh I didn't know this Charlie color said
Gloria the original was directed by John
cassavettes yeah he was a great director
of realistic type movies yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was also in wasn't he also in uh
he was an actor as well like he was
wasn't even Rosemary's Baby I think he
played guys so your sound or the movie
She's gonna want to see it no it was
good yeah I like John cassavetes I've
liked his other movies but um but yeah I
haven't seen them all but like yeah I
like his movie so yeah so we definitely
have to see that now yeah so [__] man
like we have to see Gloria we have to
see True Romance we're never gonna like
live long enough
there's a there there's an element of
just kind of natural sexism
because this is an older guy and a young
girl they're automatically people
jumping into this pedo [__] and the
other one it was an old lady and a
little kid everyone jump to the Peter
thing well but that little boy was
[__] protecting like he was the man
you know that [__] you know what I mean
you listen to me and you're my
girlfriend now that type of [__] you
know just weird well in some ways I see
that though because like the dynamic
isn't quite the same yeah and plus the
kid in this is a lot younger so it's not
kind of like he's on like the cusp of
puberty yeah no he was so it's not quite
as weird because when he's just like a
little kid then you're just kind of like
oh it's just cute yeah you know what I
mean like and I'm not saying that it's
like it doesn't happen I'm not saying
that like older women don't like abuse
like little boys that age because they
absolutely do I'm just saying that when
you see it in a movie I don't think
people are immediately gonna jump to
that because they just think oh cute he
thinks he's the boss you know what I
mean because he's just so little so I
think that's probably why I think that
the problem people had with this one
like I said was because one Natalie
Portman was clearly like on the cusp of
puberty she was like 12 years old and
also maybe because the director also
yeah like married married a teenager
yeah so I can understand that's a little
problematic yeah that's not what
happened in the movie though so uh
so you can kind of yeah it doesn't
happen yeah it doesn't happen in the
movie in the movie like I said maybe
that's where the idea came from but like
like I said the actors were like no
let's not and the movie is just people
helping each other yeah really that's
that's all it is and uh that they that
there was there was a love between them
uh but it wasn't a sexual love yeah not
on his partner not on his part and I
think even by the end I think she was I
think she had kind of realized too it
was impossible that he was more like a
dad figure than like
she was wishing that was her boyfriend
yeah which like I said is very common
for girls that age I know it's like
uncomfortable for people to think about
but
um girls that age do fantasize in that
way so they want to be women it wasn't
unusual it doesn't make it you know it's
understandable they want to be women
yeah boys that age want to be want to
grow up be men yeah yeah you're just
right yeah so it's not you know when you
think about it in that context it's not
that creepy uh and xanada is here so yes
the one that sent us this movie so yeah
thank you very much I really really uh
enjoyed revisiting this one because I
had never seen the extended
International cut and I don't think you
had either had you no because I just saw
the American cut like earlier so it was
it was nice to see like all the contacts
like put back in yeah uh and then he
says I sent you guys some guy Richie
films yeah he said that he sent us um
snatch and uh Lock Stock and Two Smoking
Barrels yeah so I'm like because I've
seen both of those and I really and I I
think I've recommended them to you like
several times I think you would really
like them so like if you get into like
British crime because remember I made
you watch sexy beast yeah because like
because I know I don't remember if it
was xanador or Louis that sent us that
but um yeah I really like that I think
that I saw that in the theater and you
really like that but I was like there's
a whole sub-genre of British crime
movies that you would probably really
dig yeah you should also see layer cake
because Daniel Craig yeah yeah you've
been sending me a lot of good movies
lately I'm gonna send you some uh retro
uh used uh m16a2 Furniture when I get a
chance
I know what you got you're gonna get
we're gonna get that dissipator looking
good
well there you go yeah that's a whole
good exchange yeah one I have doesn't
have any heat shields though I'm gonna
get you something else
yeah the heat shields are missing but I
got some I got some hand guards Colt
hand guards but there's no heat shields
to them I know a place to get some that
has heat shields though
okay yeah
somebody said earlier that they liked
the gun talk so oh yeah so you're so
you're safe yeah I don't mind well they
got guys in here that are into that [__]
yeah yeah it's a part of movies too
American culture it's all in the [__]
movies and
well yeah a lot of us buy guns well I
mean it was in or whatever you know yeah
well and the thing is like I can't you
know be I can't be too thing about it
because it's like um you know I dork out
about particular details in movies as
well so it's like you know it's just not
not the same things that you would dork
out about but you know
Santa said I don't even like a lot of
movies but the ones I send are hopefully
good yeah I'm very selective about
movies I like yeah I mean you know
trembling color said what did you what
do you think about the early found
footage maybe the Last Broadcast I
watched it lately and liked it all up
until the end which I think they [__]
the bed with the twist I kind of agree
with you on that um I actually did a
review of it I can't remember if I put
it on this channel or my other channel I
think I put it on this channel so it'd
be under my flickers of fear thing and I
think it was like a few months ago that
I did it yeah if you don't know it was
like it was a found footage movie that
came out like 10 months before The Blair
Witch Project and just got like
completely subsumed by The Blair Witch
Project hype but it's actually pretty
decent I really like the premise in the
premise of it is even kind of similar to
Blair Witch but they didn't rip each
other off because they were working at
the same time but um
yeah I mean I didn't mind the ending but
I don't know I I thought they didn't
really I thought it was inadequately set
up I don't really like want to spoil it
for anybody that hasn't seen it because
it does have like a really big twist but
I don't know I didn't love it but I
wasn't that mad at it if that's it
wasn't that bad I was you know what I
mean
yeah uh all right so are you ready to
like uh wrap things up okay so we're
gonna wrap things up so tomorrow's
Monday and that means it's a haunting
Mondays and on this show on tomorrow
night's show we're gonna be doing the
next episode in season five which I
think is called The Uninvited
I think is what and I was like looking
at the pictures from it and stuff I kind
of vaguely remember it I think it's a
it's another one that takes place in
like a restaurant or a bar like instead
of a house so I know we've seen it a
couple times but I don't remember all of
the details so that's the one we're
gonna do so if you wanna watch The
Uninvited it's from season five episode
eight I think uh it is so if you want to
watch it before we do it tomorrow night
then that's what we're gonna do so thank
you very much for dropping by and
hanging out with us this evening again
thank you xanada for sending us this
movie because we really did enjoy it and
we'll see you guys again tomorrow night
good night